hi everyone
this is professor m does science and
today i want to talk about the
schrodinger equation
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the drawing
equation is one of the key equations in
quantum mechanics
it tells us about the time evolution of
quantum states
in this sense it plays an equivalent
role to that of newton's second law in
classical mechanics
which tells us about the time evolution
of a classical system so without further
ado
let's get started with the schrodinger
equation let's go
postulate 6 of quantum mechanics tells
us what happens to a quantum state as a
function of time
we describe quantum states with cats and
now we introduce their time dependence
with this time variable
t the time evolution of such a cat is
then governed by the schrollinger
equation
written here this equation is a
postulate
this means that it is not something that
we can derive instead what we find is
that all the predictions coming out of
this equation
are confirmed by experiment
so what does the joining equation tell
us on the left hand side we have the
derivative of the state
psi with respect to time and this
captures the time evolution of the cat
it is also multiplied by the imaginary
unit i and the constant h-bar
this constant h bar is equal to planck's
constant h
divided by 2 pi and is called the
reduced planck constant
this time derivative is then equal to
the right hand side which is an operator
h acting on the state psi this operator
plays a key role in quantum mechanics
and is called the hamiltonian
we know that operators in quantum
mechanics are used to describe physical
properties
so the central question to ask is what
physical property does the hamiltonian
represent
the answer is that the hamiltonian
represents the total energy of the
system
so if we look back at the schrodinger
equation it tells us that the time
evolution of the system is governed by
the total energy of the system
so what can we deduce about the time
evolution of a quantum system from the
schrollinger equation
the key is that the equation is a first
order differential equation in time
this is key because all first order
differential equations can be solved
unambiguously
by finding first the general solution
and then providing a boundary or initial
condition
once we have these psi of t will tell us
exactly
what the state of the system is at any
time t
it is critical that we understand what
this means the time evolution from the
jollinger equation is completely
deterministic
there is no ambiguity or probability
involved
once we know the state of the system at
any point in time say t0
then the drawlinger equation tells us
exactly what the state of the system
will be at a later time t
so question you may have now is given
that the schroedinger equation
is deterministic where does the famous
probabilistic nature of quantum
mechanics come from
as we discussed in the videos on
measurements it is postulate 4
of quantum mechanics that introduces a
probabilistic dimension
but that is only relevant when we
perform a measurement of some physical
quantity
as a refresher you'll remember that when
we measure a general property
a of the system then we need to consider
the associated operator a
and its eigenvalue equation
once we have this the outcome of the
measurement can only be one of the
eigenvalues lambda n
of the operator a associated with the
property we're measuring
and we cannot say in a deterministic
manner which eigenvalue we'll get
all we can say is that if our system is
in a state psi
then the probability of getting an
eigenvalue lambda n is given by this
expression
there is a second important point about
measurements which is that if we start
with a system in state psi
and we do perform the measurement of
quantity a we will get some eigenvalue
say lambda n
as the outcome of the measurement at
this point postulate 5 of quantum
mechanics tells us that
after the measurement the state of the
system changes dramatically
and becomes vn the eigenstate associated
with the eigenvalue lambda n that we got
as the outcome of the measurement
so what we have to do now to properly
understand time evolution in quantum
mechanics
is to combine the schrodinger equation
with measurements
imagine that we start with the state psi
at time t 0.
then for as long as we don't perform any
measurements the drawing
equation which i abbreviate by s e here
tells us what the system will be at a
later time t1
this time evolution is deterministic
now let's say that at time t1 we perform
a measurement of property a
then as a result of this measurement we
can obtain any of the eigenvalues of the
operator a up here
and before we do the measurement all we
can say is the probability
of getting any of these eigenvalues
however
once we have performed the measurement
we do get a specific eigenvalue
say lambda m if we then follow postulate
5 the state of the system
changes from psi to um
and this is the probabilistic step
and another important point to note is
that the times here and here are the
same
and that's because the state changes
instantaneously with the measurement
so right after the measurement the state
of our system is um
the subsequence time evolution is again
governed by the schrodinger equation
and we can determine the state of the
system at a later time in a completely
deterministic manner until we perform
another measurement
from this discussion we see that time
evolution in quantum mechanics is quite
different
to that in classical mechanics in
classical mechanics
the equivalent to the schrodinger
equation is newton's second law of
motion
given a starting state for a classical
system we can calculate the state at a
later time
in a deterministic manner by solving
newton's second law
additionally we can measure a property
of the system at any time
t without affecting the system so we
only have to solve the time evolution
once
and we know what will happen to the
system at any later time
in quantum mechanics we also have a
deterministic time evolution of the
state of the system
psi but it is only true as long as we
don't perform
any measurements on the system the
moment we perform a measurement
we introduce a probabilistic element by
radically changing the state of the
system to the eigenstate associated with
the measurement outcome that we get
we then have to solve the joining
equation again starting with this new
state to see how it will continue
evolving in time
to learn more about this rollinger
equation in the rest of the video we're
going to assume that we're not making
any more measurements
so we're going to have only the
deterministic time evolution given by
the joiner equation
now that we know that this rolling
equation tells us about the time
evolution of our system
it is obvious that we will spend a lot
of time with this equation when we do
quantum mechanics
whenever we do that we have to consider
two questions
the first concerns the drawing equation
directly although the equation is
universal
every system has a different energy so
the hamiltonian h
which is the operator representing the
energy of the system will be different
for every system
so the first question is what is the
hamiltonian of the system under study
writing down hamiltonian is actually
relatively straightforward
on the one hand we have the kinetic
energy of each particle in our system
and in a non-relativistic setting the
kinetic energy of each particle is given
by the momentum squared divided by two
times the amount of the particle
the second contribution to the total
energy is the potential energy
and this term takes a different form for
every system
for example if we have two electrons
each of charge e
then the potential energy is given by
the coulomb interaction
this is just an example but you can find
many more in our other videos where we
build the hamiltonians for systems
ranging from atoms all the way to
materials
okay so once we have specified our
system through the hamiltonian
we get to the second question how do we
solve the schrollinger equation
at this stage we can distinguish two
situations the first corresponds to what
we call
conservative systems and these are
systems in which the hamiltonian itself
is time independent
as we'll see in a moment we can actually
solve this rollinger equation for a
conservative system
once and for all so this turns out to be
an easy case
the second case corresponds to systems
with a time dependent hamiltonian
the solution for time dependent
hamiltonians is much more complicated
so we're going to leave the solution for
later videos
as we just discussed when we have a
conservative system in which the
hamiltonian is time
independent then the solution of the
drawing equation is in fact very simple
as always when we solve a problem in
quantum mechanics the very first thing
we have to do is to decide in which
basis of representation we're going to
solve the problem
we know that in principle all
representations are physically
equivalent
but from a mathematical point of view
choosing a good representation can make
life much easier
so what is a good representation in
which to solve this rollinger equation
as you may suspect given that the
operator that features in the drawing
equation is the hamiltonian
describing the energy of the system then
we'll want to work in the energy
representation
so how do we define the energy
representation
we need to consider the eigenvalue
equation of the hamiltonian
h acting on u n equal to e n u n
the un are the energy eigen states and
the en are the energy eigenvalues
both of which are time independent if
the hamiltonian is time independent
the key is that a hamiltonian is a
hermitian operator because it's an
observable
so it eigenstates from a basis of state
space and this basis provides the energy
representation that we're looking for
so now that we have the energy basis u
we can expand any arbitrary state psi of
t
in this basis and as usual the expansion
coefficients cn
are given by the bracket between un and
the state
the eigenstates are time independent so
all the time dependent in this expansion
is captured by the expansion coefficient
c
the next thing we can do is write the
full schrodinger equation in the energy
basis given by the eigenstate of the
hamiltonian
we do this in the usual manner by acting
with the bra u n from the left on both
sides of the equation
as u n is time independent we can move
it inside the derivative here
for the right hand side this here gives
e n times the bra u n
because the hamiltonian age is hermitian
so we can act on the bra with it
putting this together we get i h bar d d
t of u and psi of t
equals e n u n psi of t
these are just the c and expansion
coefficients which provide the
representation of the state in the
energy basis
so we end up with a first order
differential equation for the cn
coefficients
we can now rearrange the equation like
this
we can integrate both sides from t0 to
t1
the integral on the left-hand side is
the logarithm of c and t
and the integral on the right hand side
is trivial
putting in the integration limits we get
this
and exponentiating we get cnt1
equal to cnt 0 e to the minus i
en t1 minus t0 over hbar
let's make some room and copy the final
expression we got for the time
dependence cn
with this result the time dependence of
the schrodinger equation for
conservative systems is always the same
and we only need to follow this recipe
first we find the energy basis in which
we want to solve the problem
to do that we have to solve the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
to find the energy eigenvalues and
eigenstates
these eigenstates provide the energy
basis
second we have to impose an initial
condition which is the state of our
system at some initial
time t zero we're working in the energy
basis so we expanded the state in these
bases
in terms of the c coefficients where the
c coefficients are given by the usual
expression
and provide the energy representation of
the state
and third at a later time t the state of
the system is obtained by simply adding
the time dependence of each c
coefficient which is found up here
and we end up with this expression
we can now see the power of solving the
problem in the energy basis
the time dependent is trivial because
each cn coefficient evolves
independently in time
and the time evolution is governed by
the corresponding energy eigenvalue
en so once we have defined the energy
basis by determining the eigenvalues and
eigenstate of the hamiltonian in step 1
steps 2 and 3 follow immediately
this means that for conservative systems
the difficult step is step one
so most of our time doing quantum
mechanics is actually dedicated to
solving this eigenvalue equation for
different hamiltonians depending on the
system we have
from a practical point of view i provide
a detailed demonstration of how we can
apply this procedure
to calculate the time dependence of a
conservative system in the video called
what happens after a quantum measurement
which you can find linked in the
description
before we move on a word about
nomenclature many people
call this equation here the
time-independent schrodinger equation
i personally don't like this
nomenclature very much and i prefer to
use the term
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
which i think is clear
however i'm pointing this out because
you will encounter this other name very
often
the next idea i want to explore is a
particularly interesting one
what happens when the initial state of
our system is an eigenstate of the
hamiltonian
this case is so interesting that it has
its own name stationary states
we still consider a conservative system
with this eigenvalue equation for the
hamiltonian
now imagine that the initial state of
our system is an eigenstate of the
hamiltonian say um
then following the procedure we just
outlined the state of the system at a
later time t
is simply given by this exponential
multiplying um we can see that psi of t
0 and psi of t only differ by this term
which is simply a global phase factor so
we know that the two states represent
the same physical situation because
global phase factors don't matter
this means that a system that is in an
eigenstate of the hamiltonian
does not change with time and this is
why we call such states
stationary states
the next idea i want to discuss concerns
the conservation of the norm
which means that if the state of the
system is normalized at some time
t 0 then the time evolution given by the
joining equation does not change the
normalization
to see this consider the norm psi of t
psi of t
at some time t we calculate the time
derivative of this bracket
using the chain rule we get the
derivative of the first term times the
second
plus the first term times the derivative
of the second
this bracket here is just the time
evolution of the cat
so we can use the drawing equation to
rewrite it like this
this other bracket is the time
derivative of the bra so we can convert
this expression to the joule space
and we get this remember that in going
to the dual space we get the complex
conjugate of all scalars
so we get a minus sign here and in
principle we should also get the adjoint
of all operators
but the hamiltonian is a hermitian
operator so we can directly write it out
without the dagger
going back to the derivative of the norm
we can now insert the derivative of the
bra into this term
to get this and then the derivative of
the ket into this term to get this
and now the result is zero this confirms
that the time derivative of the norm is
zero
so indeed the normalization does not
change with time
this makes our life easier because we
only have to normalize the state once
and then if we evolve it in time using
the schrodinger equation we don't need
to worry about normalization again
this video has a few important take-home
messages so let's finish with a quick
recap
postulate 6 of quantum mechanics tells
us how the state of a system
evolves in time and it does so in a
deterministic manner between
measurements
this time evolution is governed by this
differential equation
called the schrodinger equation in this
equation the operator
h here is called the hamiltonian and is
the operator associated with the total
energy of the system
therefore the first step in any quantum
mechanical problem
is to figure out what the hamiltonian of
our system is
once we have done that we can then move
on to solve the schrodinger equation
solving it in general is a difficult
problem but when we have a conservative
system in which the hamiltonian is time
independent then the solution is very
simple and it involves three steps the
first
is to solve the eigenvalue equation for
the hamiltonian to determine the energy
eigenvalues and eigenstates
because these provide the energy basis
in which we solve the problem
the second step is to write down the
initial state of the system
in the basis of the energy eigenstates
and the third is that the state of the
system at a later time t
is given by this
when the time evolution is entirely
captured by these exponentials
the drawing equation is so important
because it tells us about the time
evolution
of quantum states you can find a simple
example of this in our video what
happens after a quantum measurement
crucially the drawing equation features
a very particular operator
the hamiltonian which is the operator
associated with the total energy of the
system
so far in our discussion of the
postulate of quantum mechanics we've
been treating all operators as equally
important
we now see that the hamiltonian has a
special place because it is the operator
that governs the time evolution of the
system
so if you've been studying quantum
mechanics for a while and you've been
finding yourself mostly solving the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
this is the reason why for our own
examples on how to solve the eigenvalue
equation for a hamiltonian you can check
out our videos on the quantum harmonic
oscillator or the hydrogen atom and as
always
if you like the video please subscribe